[Musica]
[Risate]
la storia che voglio raccontarvi inizia
con un omicidio e il killer so io l'ho
guardata a spegnersi lentamente
finché un giorno non respirava più poi
si è irrigidita cambiato colore ma non
era un bello spettacolo
mi sono sentita eccome devo dire la
verità però ma è durata poco dopo di lei
ne uccise anche altre si è mai
dispiaciuto ma c'era come un senso di
contabilità e quello che succedeva ogni
volta ho capito di essere un serial
killer
e inutile che vi mangiate così io so che
fra di voi ce ne sono molti come me e
sono sicura che sarebbe d'accordo quando
vi mostrerò l'aspetto che aveva la mia
ultima vittima somigliava molto da
vicino
avevo quello che si chiama il pollice
nero poi ad un certo punto per i motivi
di karma insomma i destini che a brusca
insomma ci propone la vita
sono finita a studiarmi le piante fatto
un dottorato atroce cardine ska di
silenzio sarà data a lavorare con il
gruppo è credibile che studia
l'intelligenza digitale che licenzia
vegetale sembra un argomento
interessante e curioso poi che sono
anche detta mediante insomma si sono per
l sono intelligenti sono curiose sono
fondamentali per la nostra sopravvivenza
per dirigenti non hanno mica cervello le
piante in ogni caso con questo dottorato
imparato un sacco di cose utili al sacco
di cose curiose che non sapevo per
esempio sapevo che le piante ci vedono
solo sappiamo tutti le piante possono
distinguere le frequenze luminose le
piante si spostano per cercare la luce e
si spostano per fuggire
l'ombra nel regno vegetale chi ha più
luce più ricco chiama invece è più
povero ma non sapevo che probabilmente
le piante riescono a chi sa distinguere
i contorni degli oggetti è una teoria
che era già stata formulata
nell'ottocento
ci sono delle nuove evidenze un
esperimento molto curioso che è stato
fatto all'università di finanza mentre
ci lavora ma anch'io riguardava faggiano
rampicante questo fagioli era stato
messo a crescere da solo in una stanza
accanto a cui da un lato supera col
supporto e poi era stato filmato e
ricordando questo filmato si vede
chiaramente che questo fagiolo cerca di
attaccarsi a supporto non cresce in
tutte le direzioni non va a casa nella
stanza va verso il supporto come fa
sapere dove sta non lo sappiamo ma è
possibile che lo veda e che riesca a
distinguere nella forma e poi ho
scoperto anche che le piante ci sentono
notato le orecchie naturalmente e eppure
riescono a sentire come gli animali che
non hanno letti e tanti animali in un
anno le orecchie non ci capita spesso di
pensarlo perché noi li abbiamo e ci
sembra sempre che tutto debba funzionare
come funziona per noi ma nel mondo della
televisione
differenti per esempio i serpenti in un
anno le vecchie neanche li vernia nelle
orecchie eppure ci sentono
sappiamo tutti che se andiamo a
passeggio in un bosco diciamo e il
serpente spostati sto passando io per
evitare di contrarre 1 ma sbattiamo con
un bastone per terra perché il serpente
sente con il suo corpo le vibrazioni che
gli vengono trasmesse dal terreno
allo stesso modo senza una pianta in un
modo simile a quello anche noi sentiamo
la musica con tutto il corpo se ci
sentiamo di fronte ad una grande cassa
che spara la musica di un volume molto
elevato sapete vi sarà capitato che di
tre microfono pancia
questo tremore è trasmesso dai canali
meccano sensibili e trasmette
informazioni del suono
la pianta riesce a sentire per esempio
il suono dell'acqua che scorre sente le
mandibole del divano che si avvicina per
darle un morsetto insomma è veramente
straordinario quelle piatte
probabilmente possano anche comunicare
tra loro con dei suoni fatti anche
eletto dei piccoli suoni o le radici ma
non sono soltanto questi sensi vegetali
le piante hanno gusto pensate le piante
carnivore una pianta carnivora non
mangia mica qualcosa che non le piace
sanno cercare i nutrienti nel terreno
volere due le delle radici le piante
hanno un fatto estremamente raffinato e
mettono dori come sapete ma sono anche
grado di accusarli e con questi odori si
trasmettono molte moltissime
informazioni di loro linguaggio e gran
parte olfattivo infatti le piatte
comunicano tra loro non comunicano con
il senso del tatto come facciamo noi
con la voce anche se il tatto ce l'hanno
ci sono 37 delle piante sapete benissimo
la più famosa è la mimosa pò dica che
fanno lato ghiacci delle foglioline
perché pensa di essere bloccata da un
erbivoro e quindi si ritrae si difende
le piante sono sono sensibili anche al
senso del tatto appunto perché
generalmente chi si avvicina li tocca
non è animato da intenzioni amichevoli
quindi è importante che si possa si
possono difendere questa percezione e
quindi le piante ci vedono ma non hanno
occhi sentono gli odori ma nando il naso
sentono i rumori senza le orecchie
sentono i sapori senza la bocca respira
l'assenza polmoni digeriscono senza uno
stomaco ma così via andrà il fatto che
non abbiamo un cervello sia sicuri che
sia così grave per la loro intelligenza
in effetti non lo è le piante sono sono
senz'altro degli esperimenti
intelligenti perché la città di giani
senza la sua evoluzionistico si
definisce come la capacità di risolvere
i problemi e le piante risolvono
tantissimi problemi nel corso della loro
esistenza proprio come tutti gli esseri
viventi e quindi in questo senso sono
certamente intelligenti tutte queste
informazioni che ho preso a questi anni
di studio hanno cambiato la mia vita per
prima cosa abbiamo fatto sentire molto
più colpa naturalmente il mio passato da
serial killer vegetale e qui
probabilmente
iniziato il mio conto alla rovescia
perché guardando intorno
ho iniziato per la prima volta a
rendermi conto di quello che vi circonda
e elettorato ha anche fallito proprio
come un vero e proprio dottore una
malattia che non sapevo neppure di avere
si chiama pianto blindness ed è poi la
malattia per la quale se io chiedo chi
di voi in questa fotografia vede due
elefanti chi pensa che la descrizione di
questa fotografia proteste con
l'espressione due elefanti sia corretta
può alzare la mano io non vedo le
mancanza te ma credo che sia natante e
di genere questa è la risposta più
diffusa
eppure sono solo due delle migliaia
senza altre centinaia di esseri viventi
è raffigurato in questo modo le piante
tendiamo spesso a darle per scontate le
piante per cui sono un po la carta da
parati
il problema risiede in un meccanismo
evolutivo non è colpa nostra realtà alle
piante non sono mai stato un pericolo
per noi la loro presenza
naturalmente ci accompagna dalla nostra
comparsa sul pianeta ma non essendo mai
stato un problema
i nostri meccanismi evolutivi si sono
strutturati in modo tale da farci
focalizzare su quello che invece poteva
diventare una difficoltà o un'occasione
ho una risorsa per noi quindi quello che
si muove gli animali in questo caso
quindi una volta curata la flat
blindness cioè la siciliana nei
confronti del mondo vegetale
ho cominciato a guardarmi intorno e mi
sono meravigliata moltissimo non so se
qualcuno di voi è già guarito da questa
mattina
siamo circondati dalla durante ed è
bello essere circondati dalle piante
perché le piante città asservita gli
ultimi studi dimostrano le fino alle
piante per esempio si guarisce meglio ci
si concentra di più generale l'aria è
più buona il clima migliore ma ci sono
proprio delle dei vantaggi a vivere e ad
essere circondati dalle grate
meno male perché le piante sono il 96
per cento della vita sul pianeta
quindi se andiamo al pianeta terra e lo
guardiamo dall'altro dobbiamo senz'altro
immaginarlo con un pianeta verde noi e
tutti gli animali
rappresentiamo soltanto col piccolissimo
4 per cento quindi pensate che piccoli
sia un confronto alle piante eppure
continuiamo a disboscare una su cinque
specie vegetali attualmente il rischio
di estinzione non sappiamo nemmeno
queste piante che meravigliose
caratteristiche possono avere quali
malattie possono curare pensate che solo
l'anno scorso che abbiamo scoperte oltre
1.700 nove specie non le conosciamo
ancora non sappiamo neanche esattamente
come funzionano cominciando a guardarmi
attorno a me non dei giardini
necessariamente ma per strada in ogni
occasione accorgendomi di queste piante
improvvisamente il mio pollice la vera
ho cominciato a diventare verde è
cominciato guardando le piante a capire
se una piatta stava bene stava male e
facilissimo e resta
basta guardare che aspetto come una
tutti noi
alcuni hanno molto colorito le foglie
spenti altre si vede che magari hanno
bevuto troppo hanno sete e poi mi sono
accorta anche di un'altra cosa e il
piante così importanti per noi che sono
il nostro habitat ma i posti che
costruiamo noi non sono un abitato per
loro nelle nostre città per esempio gli
alberi vivono così questa quando stanno
bene in generale perché hanno una grata
per poter respirare per raccogliere
l'acqua piovana spesso stanno anche
peggio di così le loro radici sono
bruciate dall'asfalto schiacciate sono
tagliate le aiuole sono spesso troppo
piccole sono separate tra loro pratica
le piante nelle nostre città e non di
città se stanno
avendo sempre di più nel pianeta ma non
ha più la capacità di riprodursi da sole
gli abbiamo tolto la possibilità di
vivere
naturalmente è andato in giro e la
prendo questa cosa e portando le piante
da certo punto ho notato questi cosa
sono
sono i semi di un albero non so che
albero sia esattamente ma cosa importa
questi per esempio li ho raccolti ieri
qui c'è un parchetto sono i semi di
quattro o cinque alberi differenti che
ho cominciato a raccogliere i occupava
da quando li riporto a casa l'impianto
poi giardino pieno di nespoli querce
privi i limoni e pieno di piante che ne
attesta esattamente cosa sia sono alberi
ma ci sono anche i fiori ci sono piante
di tutti i tipi e quando queste piante
crescono leva trapiantare faccio un buco
e gli metto giù poi esco riguardo sono
felice penso che a compenso che vada a
quel punto termine
così cominciamo con te giocata vecchio
negativo
ma come dice le patteggiato siti web
come viaggio nella vita di questa pianta
germania costa che oggi non si sa parli
già che il vostro bianca
piantiamo inviare anche l'ampia mole
[Applauso]
[Musica]